nous allons vous présenter un nouvel ami
de récré a2 qui s'appelle corbier qui
nous fera rire toutes les émissions qui
chantera pour vous et pour nous alors
pourquoi nouvelle formule savez quand on
écoute une chanson la mélodie et les
paroles souvent nous donne des images
n'est pas forcément rapport avec la
chanson et c'est ce que j'aimerais que
vous fassiez vu le nombre de dessins que
vous m'envoyez je sais que vous aimez
décidé alors je compte sur vous vous
allez écouter la chanson disque aurait
vu cela va vous donner des idées des
images et vous allez vite en faire un
dessin le plus beau est bien sera
récompensé bien entendu vous êtes prêt
vous avez bien compris alors tout de
suite voici notre nouvel ami nacré à 2
corbier écoutez le
[Musique]
quand les rois mages sont arrivés
au nouveau-né qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
donnée
ils ont tiré de leur poche du swing des
roudoudous durée glisser des boules de
gomme
ils ont fait tomber de leur manche du
chocolat et leurs babouches était plein
de bars de nougat
quand les rois mages soute
vim
mon papa qu'est ce qu'ils ont importé
ils ont sorti des havanes leur sac à dos
des bouteilles de champagne pour l'apéro
une carte famille nombreuse et scène c
et il a presque le chômage et on n'aura
plus bf cran
maj sont arrivés
la maman qu'est ce qu'ils ont
d'abord ils ont fait des pompes ce et la
vaisselle
ils ont préparé la bouffe vider la
poubelle
ils ont brisé les choses à être lavé par
terre
elle puise ont demandé à la mairie une
aide ménagère
quand les rois mages sont repartis
au village questions
on a dit
i
pour être tout à fait franc
ti banane ne s'était pas dans un village
m
la zone où
les magies n'était pas plus roi que toi
et moi
d'ailleurs il arrive une barbe et ses
nouveau-nés il s'appelait olga
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]